[Musique]
assurer le bon jour attends je te
rappelle howie lundi que moi au lieu
notre dame de paris notre dame de paris
c'est par là je crois ok faites pas
votre français et dites moi où les
notre-dame de google comprends pas oui
notre dame de paris
vous les français vous dites toujours le
mauvaise direction soit vous connaissez
pas votre pays soit vous êtes des sales
racistes de mer dont je sais pas vous
êtes jaloux de notre puissance mondiale
ou quoi non c'est par là
ok ça fait deux jours que je suis apparu
le capital du love
ok elle peut la pisse au cul c'est
dégueulasse porter l'autonomie et le
cadre d'un accueil au french people à
des glaces alors faites un effort
d'accord d'accord d'accord
d'accord
dat vob dat ce my boys boys boys dans
leur carte vais je vais voir où on en
est alors nous en plus de pas connaître
tu payes vous êtes super je n'ai jamais
en france c'est vraiment puis de la mer
dans la france c'est la chiasse de
l'europe ok donc nous on est là je m'en
fous de savoir où en est la nôtre dame
je m'en fous je vais me faire ma photo
et je vais me casser ok ok notre dame de
paris
[Musique]
celle du client
k -o
[Musique]